in October of 1347 Devastation and
disease came to the shores of Europe 12
ships from the Black Sea docked in the
port of Messina in Sicily and as
Citizens waited on the docks to welcome
the sailors home they were horrified to
discover that almost everyone aboard the
ships had been lost they were still
there but they had succumbed to a
mysterious illness their bodies covered
in terrible black boils everyone was
warned to get away to let the
authorities clear these ships of death
out of the harbor but it was already too
late the Black Death had arrived the
people of Europe had heard rumors
Whispers of a great pestilence working
its way through the trade routes of the
East leaving desolation in its wake as
it raged through China India Persia and
Syria there were stories of swollen
boils under the armpits of fever chills
aches and pains and before long death
the illness worked so swiftly a man
could go to bed in the picture of
perfect health and be dead by morning
now this same pestilence had landed in
the harbor and come up onto land and the
Invisible Hand of Death and sickness had
a grip on everyone's throats shortly
after the plague's arrival in Italy it
spread to the port of Marseille in
France then continued on to Rome
Florence Paris Bordeaux Lyon and London
as the pestilence continued its
uncontrollable spread people everywhere
were terrified something was invading
their homes and taking their loved ones
and they had no idea what was causing it
or how to treat it some doctors believed
that the disease was caused by miasma
foul-smelling air that carried the
plague on its Breeze others believed it
to be a spiritual sickness spread when
the Airborne Spirit of a sick man
floated out of his eyes and attacked a
healthy person unfortunate enough to
make eye contact with him others thought
it must be divine punishment God's
answer to the Relentless sins of mankind
amidst the chaos and mistrust the
finger-pointing and desperate attempts
to find something anything to blame
doctors did their best to treat patients
with a limited information they had
proposed cures range from useless and
ridiculous to the downright dangerous
some Physicians prescribe bloodletting
pricking open veins to let the disease
flow out of the patient's body along
with most of the blood they needed to
stay alive others had the sick take
baths in vinegar and Rose Water which
wouldn't harm them but did little to
stop the progress of disease some cures
were expensive calling for an emerald to
be ground into powder and mixed into a
glass of wine other treatments were
honestly a fate worse than simple death
and included drinking one's own urine
ingesting snake skin and precious metals
and drinking the pus from lanced boils
working with plague patients was a
potentially deadly undertaking and the
few doctors brave enough to take on the
task needed to take as many precautions
as possible they were outfitted with a
specialized uniform an ankle length
Overcoat gloves boots and a bird-like
mask ending in a pointed beak The Mask
contained a rudimentary respirator-like
device filled with dried flowers and
herbs spices camphor or a vinegar sponge
they believed that by overpowering any
potential bad smells the scented mask
would protect against the diseased air
the costume include a wide brimmed
leather hat and a wooden cane used to
examine patients without touching them
all in all a plague doctor's attire was
easily recognizable and more than a
little ominous in appearance however
what might be unsettling to see today or
even a signifier of an especially
dangerous and misguided humanoid anomaly
contained by the SCP Foundation was once
a symbol of Hope in a dark time seeing a
man enter town in a long dark cloak a
leather hat and a bird-like mask meant
that perhaps all was not yet lost and so
as news traveled about a mysterious
illness stealing souls in the night
turning their bodies into masses of
infectious boils that needed to be
rounded up and burned in pits outside of
town the people of a tiny French Village
were anxiously awaiting the arrival of
one such plague doctor they hoped a
physician would arrive before the first
person fell ill but they could feel the
cloud of illness creeping ever closer it
was a joyful day when one morning a
young man ran through the town square
banging a pot and pan together and
crying out a doctor is here a doctor has
come to town indeed just behind the
young man came a stranger dressed in
Long Black robes and wearing a
wide-brimmed hat however instead of the
beaked Mask this man's face was covered
in a rather curious manner he wore a
white porcelain mask Frozen in a
permanent smile behind the eyes an open
mouth the villagers could only see
Darkness this must they thought be some
new preventative measure some protective
gear he had brought with him from
whatever medically Advanced City he had
just been in still before getting their
hopes up the people wanted to be sure he
excused me an older farmer a respected
pillar of the community approached the
masked man are you a physician indeed I
Am The Stranger replied cheerfully I
have reason to believe the black death
will shortly come to this little town
and I was sent here to provide my
services to anyone who may need them in
case there was any question about his
identity he produced from his side a
large doctor's bag filled with tinctures
and tools with Rags soaked in vinegar
and vials of ground up eggshells and
saffron the townspeople couldn't help
but feel lucky that such a well-equipped
physician had come to their town to arm
them with the tools they needed to
combat the plague later that day their
Fortune seemed to double when yet
another stranger strode into town this
man was dressed far more traditionally
in the Garb of the people had come to
expect from a physician tasked with
treating the Black Death this man was
dressed in long dark robes leather
gloves boots and a beaked mask he
carried a bag similar to that of the
first doctor the same old farmer
approached the doctor curious to see two
newcomers on the same day he couldn't
remember the last time he saw so many
strangers arriving in their little
Hamlet at the same time have you'll come
to help us doctor he asked fear not my
good fellow I have I am here to fight
the great pestilence and I will lend you
all of my efforts and years of medical
knowledge tell me are there any infected
yet I would be happy to treat them the
farmer shook his head we are all healthy
here sir but it is fortuitous indeed to
have two great Physicians here to Aid Us
in these troubling times the doctor
tilted his head to the side perplexed I
assure you I am traveling quite alone
the man who arrived before you the
farmer insisted come and meet him I'm
sure you too will have a lot to talk
about more than a little confused the
plague doctor followed the farmer to the
town's Tavern where he was ushered to a
table that had one occupant the man in
the white mask he greeted the doctor
with that Frozen porcelain smile and a
tone that was filled with mannered
Congeniality ah another doctor welcome
my dear colleague it would be a pleasure
to work with you the plague doctors had
a cross from a mask and stare at him
inquisitively I was unaware that there
would be another physician in town
please forgive my confusion not a worry
the masked smile seemed to widen though
of course that was impossible it will be
a relief to have someone else to share
the burden I am certain we will work
together quite well tell me the flight
doctor begin how did you come to hear
the need for a doctor in this town it is
my understanding and not have fallen ill
thus far rumors that is all and in times
such as these one can never be too
careful after all we took an oath to
help those in need did we not the plague
doctor couldn't Place why but he felt
strangely apprehensive about this fellow
in the white mask something about him
did not seem quite right from his
untraditional choice of attire to the
rustling sound inside of the man's bag
to the strange droplets of something
black that I gathered on the table in
front of him still perhaps the
exhaustion of his journey had put him on
edge many hands make for lighter work
and he should be grateful for the
assistance promised he was used to
working alone but he would simply have
to just besides it was entirely possible
no one would become ill at all and the
letter he had received summoning him to
the town was based on inaccurate
assessments of the area's risk he would
stay a fortnight evaluate the health of
the people and if nothing of important
arose he would travel onward to the next
town and continue his endless battle
against the pestilence but before that
Fortnight could pass someone did fall
ill the Old Farmer's Wife ran to the
tavern in the early hours of the morning
only two days after the doctors came to
town the plague doctor was already awake
when she arrived sipping a cup of tea
and eating a piece of toasted bread with
butter she begged him to leave his
breakfast and come inspect her husband
immediately her husband had collapsed
while milking the cows and nothing she
did could wake him his forehead felt hot
to the touch slick with sweat as he
looked the plague doctor could see that
the farmer's body was covered in The
Telltale boils that he had seen so many
times before he instructed the woman to
stand back to stay away away from her
husband lest she catch his sickness then
he began a thorough inspection using his
Cane to lift the man's arms and check
beneath them sure enough there were more
boils there your husband is very ill he
told the Weeping Woman but I assured you
madam I will do my best to make him well
we will Begin by letting the blood from
these areas he pulled a scalpel from his
bag and began the procedure this will
release the humans that have gathered in
excess and allow his body to regain
balance it will not work a voice behind
him Disturbed his careful work and the
plague doctor turned around to see the
white masked man watching him from the
doorway I beg your pathan the plague
doctor straightened this man needs a
different cure please allow me to treat
him the plague doctor hesitated
uncertain about having his methods
questioned but the pleading cries of the
farmer's wife persuaded him to step back
and allow his colleague to try his own
treatment very well I will let you work
the plague doctor left the room to give
the white masked man some privacy the
farmer's wife joined him the two sat in
the front room of the house waiting for
whatever news the other doctor might
bring finally after many hours he
returned I am very sorry the man's white
mask now bore the expression of a deep
sorrowful frown his gloved hands were
covered with blood your husband's
condition was fought to advance if I had
arrived sooner to treat him and if his
blood had not been let so hastily by my
colleague perhaps I would have saved him
but he is with the angels now the woman
began to cry again and as she wiped her
eyes the plague doctor noticed the
masked man do the same wiping something
thick and black from the eye holes of
his mask strange and then there were the
words he said words that offended the
doctor to his very core are you implying
that I am to be held responsible for
this lost patient he demanded of course
not it was the plague that took his life
but well we will never know exactly what
might have happened if I had arrived to
treat him first never mind that's not to
dwell on such hypothetical matters the
white Mass man held out a cup to The
Grieving Widow filled with something
dark and viscous my dear lady in caring
for your husband you were exposed to his
sickness you will take ill and follow
him into death if you do not care to
prevent the plague from taking in you
please drink this it will keep you safe
before the plague doctor could ask what
the unfamiliar medicine was the woman
had already taken the cup with trembling
hands and drank its contents in one
swallow please do call on me if anything
else troubles you my condolences for
your loss and with that the white masked
man was gone the farmer was the first
citizen to succumb to the black plague
but sadly he would not be the last once
the disease had its hooks in the town it
was going to be difficult to root it out
in spite of taking the strange Curative
drink the farmer's wife was lost only a
few days later all throughout the town
more and more grew ill had it seemed
there was no relief in sight the plague
doctor did his best to treat the
patients as they came providing them
with homemade tinctures of herbs and
wild mushrooms cleaning their wounds
with distilled Spirits bathing them in
the purest of vinegar he even resorted
to some of his more experimental
treatments those his colleagues in Paris
had questioned had dismissed as far too
close to the occult and far to remove
from science he took the blood from a
healthy cow and attempted to transmit it
into a human patient he deliberately
stopped the heart and then started it
again with the Venom of an exotic Snake
Still he was unable to save any of them
he was beginning to lose faith in
himself and the people of the village
were following suit slowly the families
of the sick were beginning to bring
their loved ones to the man in the white
mask instead trusting only him to help
them and somehow help them he did the
plague doctor could never be sure what
the white masked man was doing his
supposed colleague was secretive about
his methods never allowing himself to be
observed he would not leave his
makeshift Workshop a room in the Attic
of a Tavern where he saw his his
patience but whatever he was doing must
have worked because for every one of his
losses there was a person whose fever
broke whose skin miraculously cleared of
blemishes and it returned home to their
life just as it was before the plague
doctor couldn't understand any of it he
had cured patients before he knew he had
his success had been renowned throughout
the land had earned him commendations
from generals and Kings but now here
ever since he met this new doctor in the
Eerie white mask something was terribly
wrong with his work perhaps the other
doctor would allow him to assist to
learn from him in his current sorry
State the plague doctor could only hope
to become an assistant of a great man
once he had absorbed some of his
knowledge perhaps then he could return
to his former state do as much good as
he once had one evening after he
finished his supper of vegetable soup
and crusty bread the plague doctors
summoned discourage and decided to go
upstairs and pay the masked man a visit
has he lifted his fist to knock on the
door her he could hear muffled voices
coming from the other side he was not
ordinarily one to eavesdrop but
something in the tone of the
conversation made him hesitate and
listen for a moment I'm afraid you might
be right the mass said there is
something unusual about the other doctor
I do not wish to cast aspirations but it
seems as if the plague only began to
appear here once he arrived in town do
you think he brought the disease with
him the other voice belonging to the
local judge replied I am sorry to say
that I do or what can be done to stop
this to drive the plague out of our
community the judge asked in my opinion
there's only one choice the doctor must
leave this town by choice or by force
dead or alive that will be up to him the
plague doctor clapped a hand over his
beak in shock conspiracy against him but
why he could hear rustling on the other
side of the door someone preparing to
open it he must hide before they spotted
him he ducked into to a closet shutting
the door behind him and tucked himself
away in the dark as the judge's
footsteps passed by outside finally it
fell silent with a sigh relief the
plague doctor pushed open the closet
door but there waiting for him was that
unmoving pale white face this time it
was smiling a malicious gleeful smile oh
hello doctor the masked man said his
words were polite but his voice was
cruel and cold what have you done why
would you tell the people such
slanderous lies the plague doctor
demanded simple they need someone to
blame and I won't have it be me
the masked man laughed then a hollow
sound haven't you figured it out doctor
haven't your brilliant deductive skills
LED you to the answer why your cures
have done nothing why all of your
patients perish while so many of mine
Thrive you made them ill deliberately
but how and why the plague Dr ghast and
shock and horror the how is so mean to
know and take to my grave but as for the
why I'd be happy to tell you because no
one will believe a word you say I intend
to rule this town the first of many I
will make my domain and there will be no
way to inspire loyalty in a population
like freeing them from the grip of the
Black Death unfortunate that you had to
arrive and complicate my plans but you
will soon be taken care of and then I
will have nothing more to worry about
the mass cackled again triumphant and
wicked you villain the plague Dr roard
grabbing at the man's robes and trying
to yank him close enough to fight he
could not get a grip on the man but the
robes came loose and fell to the ground
revealing a horrible sight where there
should have been a man flesh and blood
and beating heart there was nothing but
a skeleton dripping black slime onto the
floor the mass covered a face of bone
and desiccated skin the body underneath
a rattling marionette propelled by a
natural evil forces it was too much for
the plague doctor to take and he did the
only thing he could think to do he
turned and ran the plague doctor grabbed
his Cane his trusty Apothecary bag and
ran out into the streets please he cried
out into the night listen to me you've
been fooled by a devil he brings
desolation not a cure he is the sickness
you're a Madman the judge cried
Vanishing a flaming torch in one hand a
pitchfork in the other you brought death
to our town and now you sprout lies
about our savior
please my dear fellow hear me you are
not safe here the plague doctor begged
the judge lunged at him with the
Pitchfork and forgetting to touch the
man with his Cane the plague doctor
grabbed his arm with his own hand to
stop the assault the judge's eyes went
wide and he dropped to the ground in a
lifeless Heap he killed him quite a
bystander they false doctor is a
murderer has the plague doctor watched
an angry mob descended on him waving
their torches and weapons they would not
hear reason they would not listen he
would have to flee the plague doctor ran
until the cries of angry townspeople in
the glow of their torches had faded into
dark in silence and then he ran some
more he ran all the way to a neighboring
town where he told stories of a
shambling corpse in a white porcelain
mask bringing a plague of illness and
deception and could only hope and pray
that these people would listen now go
check out when daybreak's scp-049 and
scp-001 can scp-049 finally cure when
day breaks for more battles of wits
between the plague doctor and the
Diabolical possessive mask